- [Narrator] This program is presented by
University of California Television.
Like what you learn?
Visit our website, or follow
us on Facebook and Twitter
to keep up with the latest UCTV programs.
(lighthearted music)
- Now we turn to our
very wonderful speaker,
Alexandra Horowitz.
Before I read anything
formal I have to tell you
that I met Alexandra
at a small workshop that we both attended
a couple of, well,
more than a few years ago,
three years ago, probably, and,
she and her husband, and,
I was immediately captivated
by their intellect.
When I heard her speak,
give her formal presentation
at this workshop,
I knew I was really in the presence
of a very special intellect,
a really penetrating mind,
which was a mind able to
express a lot of subtle ideas
in extremely accessible language.
And, she writes the way she speaks,
she speaks the way she writes,
and, it's all very beautiful,
completely comprehensible and revealing.
So, I know you're gonna enjoy her.
Alexandra Horowitz is
a well-known scientist
in animal cognition.
Her research centers on
the behavior and cognition
of the domestic dog, with
a focus on dyadic play,
metacognition, olfactory perception,
and the behaviors implicated
in anthropomorphisms of dogs.
In addition to the enormously
successful Inside of a Dog,
which spends 63 weeks at a
New York Times Bestseller,
her second book, On Looking:
Eleven Walks with Expert Eyes,
was published just this January.
Horowitz is also published extensively
in the academic world,
with articles appearing in
Social Justice Research,
Learning and Behavior,
Animal Cognition, and the
Encyclopedia of Animal
Rights and Animal Welfare,
among other publications.
She's produced a number
of popular articles
for the New York Times,
her work has been covered
in the New Yorker,
The Chicago Tribune, and Time Magazine.
Horowitz earned her BA in Philosophy
at the University of Pennsylvania,
and a PhD in Cognitive Science at the
University of California San Diego.
She's taught at Barnard College,
of Columbia University
since 2004, and is currently
Adjunct Associate Professor
of Psychology there.
She lives in New York City
with her husband, son,
and her dogs, Upton, and Finnegan.
In today's lecture, Alexandra Horowitz
will discuss how domestic
dogs, canis familiaris,
have insinuated themselves into
our society and imagination.
Having been long present
in our art and narratives,
dogs are now ubiquitous in American homes.
She will describe the dog's
historical and contemporary role,
attributions made to the dogs,
and will propose and
alternative empirical approach
to considering dogs.
Join me in giving a warm
welcome to Alexandra Horowitz.
(audience claps)
And, we'll have a short
question and answer period after her talk.
- Thank you so much, Stanley.
Hello.
I should like to express my appreciation
to the Foerster Lecture Committee,
and to Stanley Brandes,
and Dean Ann Traseri,
and Chancellor Robert J. Birgeneau
for the invitation to come
and speak before you today.
As Stanley says, I'm a
researcher of the domestic dog,
canis familaris, and as
observer of their behavior,
in natural contexts as they
interact with conspecifics
or with humans or in
experimental contexts,
as they solve problems
that we have set them.
I'm interested in animal
mind, and this research
is mostly about making
inferences of the cognition
of the members of this
species from their behavior.
Ultimately I spend a
disproportionate amount of my time
videotaping dog, coding the behavior
from videotapes of dogs, or patting dogs
in appreciation for
letting me videotape them.
(audience laughs)
These biographical facts,
viewed in the context
of the topic of this lecture series
may explain the upthrust of
my eyebrows on my forehead
after I was invited to speak here.
(audience laughs)
For the phrases Immortality of the Soul,
and Domestic Dogs do not
often find themselves
in the same academic journals.
Indeed, the study of immortal soul
and the study of dogs
seem on first pass not to
bear on one another at all.
But, of course, there's
plenty of precedent
for discussing the possibility
of the immortal souls
of dogs or of any animal.
There's been furious debate on the topic,
although the fury has been
stretched out over centuries.
In Ancient Egypt, dogs and
souls were intertwined.
Depictions of Anubis, this
dog-headed jackal or other canid,
often decorated tombs, as a
guide of deceased human souls
into the immortal realm.
Meso American cultures
repeated this motif,
leaving pottery figures of
dogs within burial sites
as chaperones of human
spirits to the underworld.
But was the dog himself
a traveler to that selfsame underworld?
Surely not.
In Ancient Greece against
the backdrop of Plato's
reasoning, immortal soul,
the Aristotelian take
on the soul was more
generous, implicating,
"that which can sense
and move" as ensouled.
Certainly dogs were included.
So, also would have been
single celled organisms
like paramecium, which flexibly
react to their environments,
or, the Mimosa pudica, a sensitive plant,
which responds in real
time to being touched
as here from top to bottom.
Immortality, for plant or
dog, is another question.
More recently, and most prominently,
from the vantage of contemporary science
was DeCartes dualism,
segregating human animals
from non-human animals with the claim that
only humans have a soul not liable
to die with the body, thus, immortal.
To animals he granted
souls but a material soul,
so intertwixed with body that it would die
when the body dies.
Of course the extension of DeCartes' claim
that the immortal soul
was restricted to humans
was that the mortal soul of animals
was shortly interpreted to
be no sort of soul at all.
Quite rapidly, one
transitions from this posture
to reducing animals to simple machinery,
thus, incapable of
feelings including pain.
Animals were hence subjected
to incredibly brutal treatment
under the guise of this philosophy.
Today, by contrast, that
many current pet owners
believe in the availability
of the afterlife for animals
is implied by a phenomenon Stanley Brandes
has recently drawn our attention to again,
the development and
success of pet cemeteries.
(audience laughs)
Such as New York's Heartsdale Pet Cemetery
and Paris' Cimetière des Chiens.
Each features inscribed
monuments on the grave sites,
formal burials and pastoral services.
Surely, those who have
buried their animals thusly
are moved to do so by the at minimum,
their sense of the continued importance
of the animal's fate after death.
And often, as when a monument reads,
"Our friend forever", or "See you later",
their anticipation that they
will, indeed, see them later.
We are thus confronted
with a range of opinions
on the matter at hand.
The insistence that animals
have immortal souls,
that animals have souls,
but not immortal ones,
and that animals have neither
souls nor are they immortal.
If you're keeping track, that leaves us
one option undiscussed,
and it will be my tack,
to suggest that the
question of soul is not
an answerable one, but that
indeed, dogs are immortal.
To clarify, I want to
suggest that the question of
the soulfulness of the animal
is not the question we should be asking.
To be sure, there's precedent
for asking questions of this sort.
For example, much current
research in non human animals
comes from comparative psychology,
which asks questions
cast in a similar mold.
Have any animals the
intelligence of humans?
Do they feel the emotions that we do?
Answers are discoverable, why,
yes, they perform admirably
like humans on this
test of problem solving,
or, no, they do not succeed
at being quite human,
at this task of social cognition.
But, with comparison to humans,
or, to what humans value
as our measure, this approach
patently circumscribes
what we are able to see
in non-human animals.
It delimits the abilities
they have to those
which mirror ours, curbs our imagination
from extending outside our humanness.
The investigation ends
before it even gets going.
It is reminiscent of the
famed exercise in exploration
and knowledge gathering
that might be called
The Safari Phenomenon.
Gone to seek animals,
the patient observer,
looking our over a
savannah, will finally see
a majestic creature approaching,
then another, then a herd.
We tend to ask "What is that?"
It's identification, a greater
kudu, is met with head nods,
and aborts most further inquiry.
We move on, no closer to understanding
the creatures we have
spotted, they have been named.
Similarly, designation of
the chimp as "like humans"
in these ways, or the rock
dove as most "unlike humans"
in these other ways brings us no closer
to understanding chimp nor dove.
I think the aim of scientific
inquiry into animals
should be by contrast, animal centered,
unpacking what their actual experience is.
The question then, of the soul of the dog,
strikes me as an illustrative example
of asking the wrong question of the dog.
Having established or determined,
or living in the hope,
that we have immortal souls ourselves,
we turn to the pup at our
feet and wonder it at them.
I do not mean by calling
this the wrong question
that that question is not germane
because the dog has no soul.
Instead, it's not relevant to the dog
because of his dogness.
In the first part, the
lion's share, as it were,
of my lecture, I'll
expand upon this point,
and try to say something
about what dogness amounts to,
and just how and why we've missed it.
Following that, I will
suggest, putting aside
the question of the dog's soulful status,
that the dog is in many ways, immortal.
For the concern with
immortality is transparently
the interest in persistence,
that our essence,
that those things we value, engage in,
or that we define ourselves
through our interactions with,
can live on in some sense
after we or they die.
In the final part of this lecture,
I'll describe how dogs
have attained immortality
through the roles they play or have played
in our perception of them
in contemporary society.
I will begin, though, with a claim,
as it has some currency these
days, that dogs have souls.
What could be meant by that claim?
It's likely that the maker
of this pronouncement
is certainly confident in his
belief that persons have souls
and has extended the same
nature to his canid companion.
Historically, what the soul
is has been changeable,
spiritual, immaterial, essential,
some component of mental experience.
Without resolving this question,
as my research with animals
addresses the fact of
and content of mental experience,
that's the part I'll focus on.
And, as an animal researcher interested
in making claims about
ability based on behavior,
any prior attribution made to an animal
is approached with caution,
in an interest in deconstruction.
What outward evidence is there
of the existence or non-existence
of the thing attributed,
the thing about the
animal to which we point
as evidence of our claim.
For instance, what behaviors
could induce people
to believe that dogs have souls?
Consider the case of Umka.
Umka is a female Brussels griffin.
Members of this breed, one
of the hundreds of breeds
for which there is a national standard,
restricting matings to maintain
a genetically ideal line,
are expected to be under 10 lbs,
and have faces with wide
set eyes, long eyelashes,
a diminutive nose, and an underbite.
These features are intended to,
in the words of the American
Kennel Club standard,
"Lend the dog an almost human expression."
Although, note that according to the AKC,
a wry mouth is a "serious fault".
(audience laughs)
In 2011, Umka was the subject of a lawsuit
filed by her owner against
Raising Rover, LTD,
a pet store which sold
Umka to her for $1600.00.
Shortly after purchasing
Umka, her new owner
became aware of various
serious health issues
in the then puppy.
Umka underwent costly
surgery to try to correct
what was discovered to be
an inherited malformation
of her hip sockets and knee bones.
In the complaint, the
attorney for Umka's owner
charges that "Even after
the first operation
"to repair her knee, Umka cannot engage
"in regular activities a
puppy should engage in,
"such as running around."
At the time of the
filing, Umka was waiting
for her next operation for her other knee.
Plaintiff requests humanity
for Umka, complaint states,
it continues, "Umka is a
living soul with a heart.
"She feels love and pain."
In some ways, Umka is
simply, under the terms
of our current law, a non-conforming
good, defective, unfit.
Pets are considered
goods, they are property,
and may be subject, under warranty,
to meeting certain
specifications, in this case,
a puppy who can engage
in puppy-like activities,
such as running, jumping,
leaping, playing.
But, above and beyond this,
the fact of Umka's soul was invoked.
She could not experience
the joys and sorrows of life
as other puppies, or indeed, we, do.
Do dogs experience love and pain?
Have they the capacity?
Neurologically, persons and dogs, indeed,
all other mammals, are
equipped with nociceptors,
pain receptors, and have
a central nervous system
that receives information
about, and responds to pain.
All move to avoid painful stimuli.
All show behaviors
sufficient to demonstrate
that they experience pain.
The answer to the question
of pain is affirmative.
Next, while love would perhaps be called
affiliative behavior in scholarly
animal research contexts,
the very fact of affiliative,
affectionate behavior
and bond forming is widely acknowledged
as a premise of social species.
It's not a stretch to say dogs love too.
There is some evidence for her soulfulness
as defined, then, at
least in terms of pain.
Umka is unable to leap on the
furniture without whimpering,
cannot run with casts on
her legs, and generally
does not engage in other
puppy typical activities.
We are given no evidence of Umka's love,
it is assumed to materialize toward owner
just when the owner
materializes in the dog's life.
But, the statement that
Umka is a living soul
is not presented as being
subject to examination,
it is a statement of conviction.
The issue for the asserters
is not whether or not
they are right in their assertion,
it is how odd we act given
this self-evident fact.
Before Umka could not leap, could not run,
or before she was even
acquainted with her adopter,
she was imbued with these traits,
by her owner and by most
dog owners, as well as
by all manner of thinkers
on the condition of animals.
But, by what authority
are we given this insight
into the dog's soulfulness,
or even any internal state?
How do we know about this dog,
or any dog's, subjective experience?
We do not.
Umka and the question of
her being a living soul,
stand as example of something
that is a more general
concern of mine as a
researcher of the behavior
of such a common and familiar animal.
We, we livers with
dogs, we already believe
we know everything about
the animal, a priori.
Prior to meeting a dog,
prior to living with a dog,
prior to looking at a dog,
we fail to use the one mechanism
readily available to us,
asking questions of a dog's
capacities and attributes,
and looking for answers
in the dog's behavior.
And, on those occasions
when we do ask questions,
we often ask the wrong questions of dogs,
we ask person questions of dogs.
This is called anthropomorphizing,
but I wanna be neutral
on whether we are correct
or not in our attributions.
I simply suggest that what
we do by assigning the dog
soulful status, or any other
set of perfunctory attributes,
is abort inquiry about the dog,
obscure our view of the dog,
stop consideration, even
of the dog in front of us.
Let us then reconsider
the nature of this animal.
Who is the dog?
The domestic dog is a
creature of some paradox
in its life among humans.
We breed dogs for sameness,
but celebrate their difference.
They are kept, yet they
are regularly abandoned.
We guide them and are guided by them.
We name one, yet, anonymously
euthanize millions of others.
They have the legal status of property
but we endow them with agency;
they want, they choose,
they demand, they insist.
We sense their animalism,
feeding them bones,
yet enforce an ersatz humanness,
dressing them in raincoats,
celebrating birthdays.
We cut their ears to be
more like wild canids,
but in breeding, shorten their faces,
to be more like primates.
We speak of their gender,
yet regulate their sex.
The dog is descended from an ancestor
of the present day wolf.
A wolf-like creature, from
which the dog diverged,
some thousands of years ago.
The matter of how many
thousands and in what manner
the divergence came is
subject to some theorizing.
But, the best evidence is this;
about 14,000 years ago, in a
few areas around the world,
homo sapiens became less nomadic,
created settlements, and came
into contact with canis lupus.
The connection for the two species was,
initially, garbage,
namely, the food remnants
that humans were leaving
outside those new settlements.
In essence, this theory
goes, humans were creating
a new ecological niche
around those waste piles.
Some wolves self-selected,
perhaps some had a lower
reactivity around humans,
and they began scavenging
food from these dumps.
One way or another, these
proto-dogs worked their way
into the settlements,
where they were tolerated,
and perhaps used once in a while as food.
This is archeological
evidence of our coexistence,
from a Northern Israel grave
site of 12,000 years ago,
an individual buried
with a hand over the body
of a five month old puppy.
Artificial selection, wherein humans
control the breeding of the animals,
took off some time thereafter,
based on human preference for behaviors,
guarding, herding, hunting,
and continued for thousands of years.
Implicitly, we may have been selecting
by preferring certain traits,
as well, physical traits.
For instance, following Konrad Lorenz,
our lab has showed that
some of the neotinous
characteristics typical of children,
big eyes, large cheeks,
are preferred in dogs.
(audience laughs)
The result is a redirection to dogs
of the feelings of
attachment typically prompted
by the infant bearers of these traits.
And, too, those dogs, or proto-dogs,
which looked at us, giving the
impression of a shared gaze,
the precondition, in some
sense, for conversation,
were certainly selected.
Their ancestors now, the
dogs of the 21st century,
are magnificent examples
of gaze sharing creatures,
nearly human, and I
use that intentionally,
as all studies confirm their
ability to use our gaze
to get information, and interpret
our communicative signals.
Here is some hint to how we
began to see dogs in our image,
they began to mind us and reflect us.
Quite late in this domestication
story, the 19th century,
the selection process turned a corner.
Breeding proceeded based not
on preferences for behavior,
but particular constellations
of physical traits,
which began to be reified as purebreds,
a concept that didn't
exist before this time.
Even more than before, dogs were designed
to suit our fancy.
This tale of domestication is usually told
through archeology or genetics,
but one might look at
dogs' representation in art
as instructive as well,
the story of how we have
thought of dogs penned on the page.
What one sees is the rise of a particular,
contemporary view of who dogs are.
The dog as confidant,
companion, bearer of secrets
and sharer of bed, sporting
sweaters and ribbons.
Now, I'm not looking here
at the symbolism of the dogs
in these images, nor the
qualities they embodied,
but at their actual depiction,
a kind of pathologist
at the museum approach,
so you will, I hope,
excuse my riding roughshod
over the hard historical
or scriptural contexts of these images.
Many early images cast dogs thusly,
the Bayeux Tapestry from the 11th century,
behaving as hunters, guards,
flushers, or, retrievers of game.
Just as importantly, on the canvas,
they were at the side of the scene,
participants but not principals.
They then began sneaking
into domestic scenes.
Underfoot,
into street scenes as with
Rembrandt's Good Samaritan here,
becoming a dog imbued image.
Nice bit of naturalism there
in his excretal posture.
(audience laughs)
And, into church, minding a column.
And, popping up almost in people's stead,
as in these Titian scenes, showing Venus,
attended to by Cupid, and a lute player,
or a dog.
Not long thereafter they trotted
from the side of the canvas
to be featured with us centrally,
in the early 17th century.
And in the 18th.
Then as show breeding
began, as objects of fancy.
Still objects, note, part of a still life,
objects collected by breeders.
And finally, most recently,
from Darwin's time onward,
they took over the canvas.
Center stage, the dog is
a subject for himself.
The portrayed; no longer
figurative, or sidelined,
this is when they became
individuals for us.
As subjects of portraits,
they are extended
the capacities of human subjects.
Indeed they are our
capacities, transplanted,
furred, though often
diminished, we assign to the dog
all manner of human attributes.
Domestication made the dog
easy to anthropomorphize,
to see as human-like, though
their shared genetic ancestry
with homo-sapiens is millions
of years more ancient
than that with canis lupus.
Indeed, domestication
itself might be considered
a process of making the
animal more anthromorphizable.
The result of thousands of
generations of selective breeding
is an animal who looks to us,
and we imagine, understands us.
He poses and it reads as familiar emotion.
We call them proud,
faithful, jealous, guilty,
feel sure that they are amazed or content,
confused, or empathetic.
Charles Darwin wrote of
his dogs as variously,
magnanimous and sensible,
shameful and modest.
I dare you to attribute
nothing to some of these faces.
(audience laughs)
This anthropomorphizing is
a natural human tendency.
Just as young children
spontaneously attribute
life to inanimate objects,
practicing animism,
in an early attempt to make
sense of the sensory chaos
of the environment,
anthropomorphism may have
arisen in our species as a strategy
to make predictable an
unpredictable world.
It is notable that in addition
to the animistic approaches
that come naturally to children,
we steep childhood in anthropomorphisms,
recapitulating in ontogeny our philogyny.
Children's books are replete
with animals clothed and shod,
and with human concerns and foibles.
The cat has a hat, the fox has socks,
bunnies run away, pigeons
yearn to drive the bus,
frogs are friends with toads.
This cavalier be-hatting
and experience attributing
we drum into our children is a repetition
and an extension of the mythology
our species long ago created.
In particular, early homo sapiens
may have found anthropomorphism
useful, to anticipate
and interpret the behavior
of non-human animals,
especially ascribing
motivations and desires
which would distinguish the
behavior of those animals
from whom one might want to flee,
from those in whom one sees a meal.
Today, some 75 million dogs live among us
in two of five US households.
They are ubiquitous and
underfoot, familial and familiar.
We humans are no longer attempting
to predict the behavior of the animal
we inexplicably find in our cave,
but we retain the vocabulary
developed to do so.
In my research, I question
the anthropomorphisms we make of dogs.
I attempt to deconstruct
them, in order to determine
both what has prompted us
to make these attributions
and if when one looks
closely at the behavior
that has prompted it, the
attributions are valid or sound.
But, what is problematic
about these attributions
after all, one might ask?
Surely their endurance
marks them as at least
not irreparably harmful in
explaining animal behavior?
I am concerned with three effects:
a perverting, a diverting,
and a subverting.
First, the perverting.
In much of Europe from
the later Middle Ages
until the 18th century,
anthropomorphisms to animals
had an extraordinary result;
animals were held accountable
for their actions.
In particular, animals
were tried and punished,
often by death, for all
manner of infractions
and trespasses against
humans and human property
from thievery to felonious
intent and murder.
In each case, as detailed by EP Evans,
the defendants were
represented by counsel,
precedent was cited, and in most cases,
a judge returned a guilty verdict,
delivered with solemnity
and often ceremony
by a specially appointed official.
The animals so convicted included flies,
horse flies, gad flies, Spanish flies,
grasshoppers, locusts, and caterpillars,
worms, snails and weevils,
mice, cows, and horses,
doves and roosters, dogs,
wolves, and dolphins,
none so frequently as the pig.
(audience laughs)
For example in 1386 in Falaise,
in Northwestern France,
a sow was sentenced to be
mangled in her head and forelegs
and then to be hanged for
having torn the face and arms
of a child and thus caused his death.
The execution was a public
event, subsidized by the city,
and for the occasion the sow
was dressed in men's clothes
and the hangman was given,
it was noted, new gloves.
In 1519, what is now Austria,
initiated criminal proceedings
against the moles or field mice,
which species was not determined,
which were accused of damaging crops,
by burrowing and throwing up the earth
so that neither grass nor
green thing could grow.
A defense attorney was assigned
but the prosecuting attorney
presented a formidable list of witnesses,
and the presiding judge
sentenced the animals to death,
but gave safe conduct for 14 days
for the pregnant and infant moles.
This kind of radical
extension of responsibility
to non-humans, based on an assumption
that it is appropriate that
they bear that responsibility,
pre-dates the Middle Ages.
A Roman custom for many years
had a dog crucified each year
on the anniversary of the day
that a local dog did not bark
upon the arrival of invading Gauls.
The responsibility even extended
to inanimate non-humans.
In Ancient Greece, a special
court tried inanimate objects
such as stones and beams
that had caused human death.
A statue that tumbled on
to and killed a passer by
was punished for murder by
being thrown into the sea.
In Russia, the bell which pealed gleefully
despite the recent
assassination of a royal figure,
was convicted of treason
and sent to Siberia.
(audience laughs)
This kind of perversion of the
impulse to anthropomorphize
is by no means an inevitable consequence,
simply a possible one.
It is not entirely in our distant past.
The circus elephant Topsy,
who in 1903 was electrocuted
in a gruesome fashion after
killing a number of her abusive trainers,
stands as stark reminder
that we are not as far
from these animal trials
as we might like to think.
And, it could be argued,
when faced with pet dogs
who are labeled aggressive and in fact,
have been aggressors, or
societal response is often
more perfunctory than our
Medieval forbears had been.
We kill them and spare the trial.
The diverting.
A far more common result of
making attributions to animals
is simply consequent
misinterpretation of their behavior.
In private homes with dogs, for instance,
these misunderstandings abound.
While the consequences are not as dramatic
as those that befell the
sow in Falaise in 1386,
they are appreciable.
For instance, it's widely
held that dogs feel guilt.
One assumes, in the way that humans may,
without the intrapsychic
Freudian conflict.
Three quarters of dog
owners surveyed in one study
expressed the belief that dogs experience
this self-conscious evaluative emotion.
Another study found dog
owners confidently asserting
that their charges "understand
the rules of the household".
(audience laughs)
The guilty look that
inspires these assessments,
including elements such
as pressing the ears back,
averting the eyes, or lowering the head,
(audience laughs)
also, dropping the tail,
wagging low and quickly and so forth,
is recognized by owners
and non-owners alike.
No less an observer of animal
behavior than Konrad Lorenz
concluded from the guilty look that we can
"assume with certainty that
it hides a guilty conscience".
(audience laughs)
The anthropomorphism here
is the step from the dog's
looking guiltily, to the
dog's feeling guilty.
That dogs realize, when they've
done something wrong, or inappropriate.
Owners are presuming
mens rea, a guilty look
indicates a guilty mind,
moving from the outward
appearance of the animal
to the confident claim
about the animal's understanding.
In our research we have shown
that this confidence is unwarranted.
In a simple experiment, we demonstrated
that dogs did not show more guilty look
when they did something for
which they might feel guilt.
Disobeying an owner, for instance.
They didn't show more than
when they hadn't disobeyed.
Ah, but when we misled
owners into thinking
their dogs had eaten a
treat forbidden to them
whilst the owners were out of the room,
and the owners scolded the dog
for this apparent defiance,
the dogs rate of the guilty look shot up.
(audience murmurs in wonder)
It was much higher than when
we misled the owners inversely
into thinking their actually
disobeying pups had obeyed.
The dogs obedience or
disobedience turned out
to have no effect on the likelihood
that that dog showed the guilty look.
Nor could owners reliably predict
what the dog had done
by assessing the look.
The look marks not
guilt on the dog's part,
but the perception of
guilt on the owner's part.
Of course, I am, and the data are agnostic
about whether dogs do actually
experience guilt in some way.
They may, certainly.
One can plainly see
a negative emotional
state manifest in the dog.
Although, the behavior
which prompts our belief
is simply due to factors not
related to their misgivings
about their misdeeds.
So, while maintaining my agnosticism,
I reject the anthropomorphism as asserted.
To assume dogs feel the emotion of guilt
is to presume apprehension that their
wrongdoings are violative of
a particular code of behavior,
and leads, inevitably, to punishment,
befitting that apprehension.
This punishment is inappropriate,
in light of the evidence.
The claim as it stands is unsupportable.
Is this analysis diminishing
of the dog's capacities?
Replacing human emotive
language with the jargon
of animal behavior unnecessarily?
I would object to this charge.
In this experimental context,
the capacity of the dog
was in full evidence.
Dogs observe their people with great care,
learn the associations
appropriate to the context,
and then apply from their
expressive toolbox, a look
which is likely to result
in less punishment for them.
(audience laughs)
It is a rather becoming look.
Indeed, dogs discover that they will be
more lightly punished if one is up front
about displaying guiltily.
(audience laughs)
Our preemptive assertions about them
divert us from seeing what
has actually been learned,
from seeing their actual capacities.
So, too, with other animals.
An animal's ubiquity leads to
claims of its ordinariness,
with it's depreciating assumptions.
Discovery of the little brown
bat's echo location ability
was delayed because it
was considered absurd
that bats might be
navigating with their ears,
let alone emitting the high
frequency sounds by which echo
they would so navigate, as Donald Griffin
discovered only 70 years ago.
That a homing pigeon might detect
the magnetic fields of the
Earth was thought preposterous.
A rat smells in stereo,
but we can only think
of their elimination as a species.
Our insistence on viewing
animals through a prism
that is based on our own
abilities or more pointedly,
our lack of abilities,
has an astonishing limiting
effect on what we see.
Finally, the subverting.
Remember that
anthropomorphisms are at best,
unproven assumptions, reliance
on unproven assumptions,
if using them is justification for, say,
fair treatment of
animals or animal rights,
could backfire, undermining the cause.
For our pure eagerness
to see intelligence,
emotional sophistication,
or other forms of
humanness in other animals,
is matched by our profound skepticism,
if it appears that we've been tricked
into believing in an
ability which is not there.
I consider this a kind
of Clever Hans byproduct.
Hans, of course, was a
horse of a century ago,
owned by a German schoolteacher,
whose action influenced the course
of animal cognition research
for that subsequent century.
His sobriquet, Clever
Hans, has come to stand
for what he could not do,
and also as a caution against
over-attributions to animals.
For Hans, his owner claimed, could count.
Shown an arithmetic
problem on a blackboard,
he tapped the sum with his hoof.
In this way, Hans could also
spell, recognize colors,
could identify musical
intervals and German coins,
and he could name the
days of the calendar.
Such was the tenor of
the time that discovery
of these presumed latent
abilities of horses,
demonstrated by Hans,
created a small furor.
While Hans had, of course,
been trained to hoof count or spell,
he was able to generalize,
solve novel problems,
and answer questions
delivered by new people.
For a time it looked as though
there was no other explanation
but that a horse was doing arithmetic.
Finally, the trick, an inadvertent trick,
unknown even to Hans' owner,
was discovered by a
psychologist named Pfungst.
When the person asking the question
did not himself know the
answer, Hans was wildly wrong.
Hans was not actually doing mathematics
or reading German, but was
instead extremely focused
on his questioners posture and breath,
such that a relaxation of the shoulders,
a raise of the eyebrows, or
a widening of the nostrils,
served as cue that he had
tapped the correct answer,
whereby the pendulum of
opinion swung the other way.
Despite the efforts of
Pfungst to highlight
Hans' astute body reading abilities,
the prevailing conclusion about Hans
was not that not only was
he not doing arithmetic,
but that he was without mental capacity,
a Cartesian automaton.
Not that the horse would make
a very good police detective
or poker player, not that the
horse had a fantastic ability
to notice what were,
to the crowds of people
who had come to watch him perform,
indiscernible muscle movements,
and endow them with meaning.
Feeling duped, we take
absence of human skill
for absence of any skill.
Hans retired but his legacy remains.
The field of animal
cognition has developed
in response to the Clever Hans phenomenon,
a constant reminder to find
the simplest explanation,
putting aside whether it is wrong,
of what an animal is doing.
Should I have succeeded in making you feel
imperiled by our anthropomorphisms,
I would be remiss
were I not to offer an
alternative approach.
We are not left with no way
to understand or connect to animals,
without our overweening attributions.
For animals are regularly
demonstrating for us
just what they're able to do,
giving us hints at their experience,
it remains only for us to
figure out how to look.
To do that, I will
return, briefly, to art.
There is a class of art
featuring a technique
and product known as anamorphosis.
The image is rendered so as to be visible,
comprehensible, from an oblique vantage,
not a straight on frontal perspective.
As in famously, Holbein's
The Ambassadors of 1533.
The anamorphic image, here,
the splash along the
bottom of the painting,
may first seem unintelligible,
skewed, meaningless,
but gains coherence on viewing
it on sidelong approach.
The portrait was to be
hung along a staircase,
and the skull becomes
intelligible from that vantage.
But, the human tendency is to first
loiter with the skewed image, and,
as with most things we encounter
that we find difficult,
try to discover some meaning
in what might actually be meaningless.
Similarly, this gallery's
lettering choice seems
intentionally opaque, unreadable,
until one comes at it the direction most
gallery goers would from
the corner of the block.
I encourage a similar, sidelong,
eccentric approach to dog behavior.
Not just looking at them
from the side, as it were,
which would just give us an
image of the dog's flank,
but instead of our offhand observations
of the dog in front of
us, observing the dog
as though he is unknown,
not yet understood.
If the dog is read anamorphicly,
we see how our role, the
role of the observer of,
and considerer of dogs is part
of the act of construction,
of who they are.
What we find is that
we've been caught in a way
of looking at dogs which obstructs
the genuine understanding of them,
what the German biologist
Jakob von Uexküll
called the umwelt of the
animal, the self-world,
wrought of those things in the environment
which can be sensed by and
are salient to the animal.
Just the imagining of the
perceptual world alone
is enough to get a quite different picture
of what say, a dog's behavior indicates.
For instance, all that gazing at us,
all that eye contact, while real,
while a mutual retina exciting activity,
is also an occasion when the dog's nose
is pointed in our direction, and for dogs,
olfaction is the primary sense.
The way to perceive, understand,
and organize his world.
He is looking, surely,
but he is more smelling.
The expanse of nasal
anatomy of canis familiaris
attests to this, with
hundreds of millions more
olfactory cells in their
nose than have humans,
as well as their corresponding
olfactory biased cortex.
And quite visibly, their mode of
olfactory investigation attests to this.
Dogs sniff at the rate
of two to three hertz,
two to three snapshots a
second of the olfactory world.
Dogs sniff into the breeze, into the fur
along a fellow dog's haunches,
into the corners of our eyes
which corners, in dogs,
release pheromones.
Along besplattered fire
hydrants and fence posts.
We ignore, diminish, even
discourage this behavior,
but it is there to see.
And, by watching sniffing very carefully,
using flow visualization techniques,
researchers have extended our knowledge
of what is happening at those moments.
For instance, the canine nostril sends
expired air out through the side slits,
which allows for near simultaneous
sniffing and expiring.
These expirations function
as what are called
turbulent canine nostril air jets,
(audience laughs)
making any nearby odorant
molecules airborne,
and pushing more smelly
stuff into the nose.
The dog's world is olfactory.
Want to ask what is the
experience of the dog?
What is his essence?
Begin and build from there,
instead of deploying our visual,
cognitive, and spiritual
language onto them.
The dog's leash,
tethering him to our side,
circumscribes who can be at the end of it.
Finally, to return to the
proposal which I began,
the immortality of dogs,
I have proof of that.
Dogs live on after they have died.
After publishing a book
on the scientific inquiry
into the minds of dogs,
into the question of the
dog's umwelt, four years ago,
I began receiving letters,
emails, usually, from readers.
I've received several
hundreds of these letters,
sharing the reader's experience
of, appreciation for,
sometimes lack of appreciation of the book
or asking question about why
their dog rolls in smelly
things he finds in the park.
Most also include something else.
A photo of their dog.
In many cases it is a
photo of a deceased dog,
whose life prompted them
to pick up this book,
read it, report to me about
it, and to share a few stories
from their dog's life.
These dogs are immortal.
(audience laughs)
I posit that what concerns
us when we think about
the immortality of souls,
is for the most part,
the immortality bit, the
keeping on past death.
Were it one's soul, one's
body, or one's left eyebrow
that continued on indefinitely,
it would be the same to us,
the indefinite us, that
unbroken continuity
is the crux of the matter.
With humans, we grant this
immortality to each other
through commemoration, through
reputation, through memory.
So, too, do we memorialize our dogs.
We remember them, capture their images
in pocket sized photos, we write of them.
When still alive there
is a way in which dogs
do not act as if bounded by time,
even as we watch them age
and see them through illness,
for their joy at reunion with
their owners is constant,
were one absent a day or a month.
Their willingness to appear to
listen to or comfort us does not waver.
They do not collect record of our faults,
our disorders or meanness,
but, keep steady company.
We see them mirror us in the
mirror of our imagination,
our idealized selves.
Their fidelity to us is not diminished
by the simple fact of death.
To have granted the dogs this immortality,
one might suggest is paradoxical,
it is but another anthropomorphism,
just of the sort which I reject.
But, a difference can be marked.
Wittgenstein, though
speaking not of dogs, said,
"My attitude toward him is
an attitude toward a soul.
"I am not of the opinion
that he has a soul."
I am concerned with our
opinions about dogs.
Matters which can be found
to be sound or unsound.
At the same time, I strike a
fully attributive attitude toward them.
I feel about them and treat them as though
they feel pride, pleasure, love.
Testing my opinions can inform
my attitudes, to be sure,
but opinions do not determine
the significance of the thing.
We should extend our
compassion and respect to dogs,
soul or no.
Their differences do not grant
us the right to dominate,
diminish, or destroy them.
So, I challenge us
thusly, step back from the
distorted image of the animal
from the human vantage.
The measure of the dog ought not be man.
Look from the side, and see
that something else is there,
the naturalized creature, the dog.
He is probably looking right back at you.
Thank you.
(audience claps)
(lighthearted music)